people were making their way back home
after work when the water burst in
it happened so fast that the trains were
still running
inside the carriages commuters were
trapped and what started as an
inconvenience
quickly became the stuff of nightmares
the trains stopped
the water rising up to the next and
nothing they could do but wait
and hope graphic videos on chinese
social media
showed apparently lifeless bodies in the
carriages and on the station platforms
cataclysm on an ordinary commute
this man is saying that hundreds of
people are trapped
and at least some of them were rescued
hernan province is home to nearly a
hundred million people
it has been hit by heavy rain since the
weekend
but nearly a year's worth fell in just
one day on the provincial capital of
zhengzhou yesterday
that's more than felon cologne in
germany with all the devastation
that brought it is the rainy season here
but the ferocity of the flooding took
everyone by surprise
across the city dozens of vehicles were
swept away made to look like toy cars
floating in the water
a huge rescue operation was in place
and chinese state media reported that a
hundred thousand people have been moved
to safety
more than 150 students and teachers were
trapped
at this kindergarten the army warned
that major dams could burst
wreaking more havoc and it is still
raining this has already been a week of
climate disasters
wildfire in the us catastrophic flooding
in europe
now china too there is no place on this
planet that will go
untouched tom cheshire is going to use
beijing